alright well as Elrod instead of a
secret project very secret you'll find
out about that secret project later this
year for now you can check out glozell
in season two of her awestruck
docu-series glow all in all about her
pregnancy via surrogate I am dying to
know the gender season two is a really
big deal cuz that's the gender reveal
which means that um that there is a
gender reveal to me that is a kid coming
so I'm very excited about that when we
start this we didn't know how was going
to end up because I was obviously having
issues and so I went to the fertility
doctor 1234 vanilla doctors and now I
have a surrogate and everything is
honest last time we talked about the
baby you said you won't feel relieved
until the baby is here right still
feeling that way I am feeling that way
because there's been so many different
things happening like you have to take
all these shots I mean you have to hope
that the surrogate takes all hearts up
now I'm not watching her every day all
day and she has her own life and we did
have a scare so I'm just like full ok so
to make a long story short I need to
make sure that she's happy are your
biggest fears about being a mom my
biggest fears about made of all is that
up well obviously I'm gonna be
embarrassing to the kid is just no way
not that I just hope that the kid has a
really good sense of humor I don't know
how it wouldnt yeah we are not you in
your house my husband's very seriously
doesn't find me funny at all so I'm
hoping that the kids like mothers
hilarious that'd be great he wanted this
fro very long very long time I wanted to
be a mom this is very excited I can't
wait to see this kid girl like I'm so
thankful that you showed up and you're
here we went through so much and very
expensive right now my baby is on
layaway i still owe on the kid so uh
just put that out there then yeah kid
needs a job so